you were on last comic standing and you
came in fourth place yeah i can't even
believe it's still is it still on i
don't know you don't even know
i've never seen it before i did it i
don't i don't yeah it has launched no
one
you know how american idol had kelly
clarkson there is no one that got famous
off that show no not at all um which was
a great thing i'd been doing stand-up
three years i was like who's from out of
town like he's doing soft chew and uh
luckily no one saw it so
so i got to then for a year after last
comic i went around i headlined because
you know enough people watched it that
you're a draw on the road i just i like
you know really just got away with it
i'm surprised no one got their money
back and then i went back to opening for
a tell in norton and featuring and going
on the road and now i'm do you feel like
yeah right did you always feel that you
wanted to be a stand-up comic was this
something like was a burning desire no i
still i'm looking to get out i'm
thinking about going to dental school so
how do you end up in stand-up comedy if
you didn't fantasize about it i was a
problem child teacher's worst nightmare
and class clown were like my little oh
really were you really a bad kid yeah i
had saturday detention every single week
really yeah like breakfast club
what would you do in school that was so
bad i was a huge wise ass i would say
the funniest thing i could think of like
i would i just like liked making myself
laugh um
and making people uncomfortable right i
just i would always um
and i never saw the teachers as like
these untouchable authorities i'd be
like listen gill
i'm really bloated today you know i just
can't be in your gym class yeah i was
like i know that you go home and you
black out and you call hookers like do i
have to pretend
because you're wearing a suit that i
should respect i just couldn't wow so
you were disrespectful did you did you
go to college did you oh you did yeah i
wasn't disrespectful to um
the teachers that like treated you like
a human being right but you know the
people who like just have you know
personality disorders who take it out on
kids
like i like justice you know so you were
a bad kid yeah who got in trouble at
school
and then you make the switch to become a
comedian somehow first time you get on
stage a disaster i imagine where do you
go to become a comedian i went to gotham
comedy club yeah it used to be on a
different street it was like small and
uh
i just walked by i done theater like i
majored in theater so i didn't have to
get over stage fright and you killed i
bet the first time the first time yeah
did you have material when you got it i
i walked past gotham and it said you if
you bring four people you can get on
stage so i call you know i'm from not
far away so i called people they came in
and i wrote um like you know horrible
jokes and delivered them like i was
seinfeld
what was the first joke that you ever
told you know i talked about sky writing
and how sky writing annoyed me because
it always faded and i had like a little
arc to the set because i was like so
this summer if you're gonna propose to
somebody guys it was like some it was
horrible was your delivery all wrong was
it just like i had like a some sense of
timing but i have a tape of it and it's
it's the most i would rather watch my
parents have sex than watch myself do
that did your family say you listen
you're destroying your life this is
ridiculous you don't know what you're
doing my mom was like when are you
headlining the apollo you are she was
she inflated my sense of self my whole
life like i thought i was i thought i
was a model
like i walk
you know then you get old enough the
kids start getting mean but i walked in
the first day of middle school and i was
like who wants it yeah
she convinced her you were the best
looking girl ever she convinced me she
was like you're an angel you sparkle
so what's the goal you want to be the
world's greatest stand-up no you just
want to make a living being a stand-up
you want to get more acting more yeah i
want to develop i want to like you know
like
what do you think don't you just have to
keep making it interesting and fun for
yourself yes you do you do yeah you
insane